[Music
] I used to work in logistics
I left this job because I
was fed up and I wanted to work
for myself doing what I like in my
little truck
today I earn half that  that
I used to win but I have a smile
every morning when I get up
and that's worth all the gold in the world is
very soft the time is not about
sharpening you it's it's all one  context
my name is thierry sweat and moulder in
paris and in ile de france
my clients are mainly
catering the food trades he
cater fishmongers and what i
do in fact i travel with my
truck i go in front  at home and I
collect their sharpened knives
so I work on their equipment and
I give them back
if I decided to do this in a
truck it's to have the
itinerant side not to be fixed to be able to
walk around all day or even the beautiful
neighborhoods  from paris
I bought the truck they were
almost empty there was  just the
work plans
and I bought the machines little by
little in fact I encounter all types of
knives in general there are about ten or
fifteen different knives of different shapes
or materials
I use different machines depending on the
problems that  I report at the start
only to make the sign and
then to make the scissors which
then for the garden tools and
little by little I equip them
[Music]
to be a grinder you have to be careful
you have to love what you do
entrusts us with equipment which sometimes is
very expensive so it must be returned in good
condition and in better condition than
it has been given to us
each professional or individual has
equipment that cuts it and we are
tired of throwing it away  people like
me who are there to repair
to give objects a second life and
that's important I feel useful